I started playing escape from tarkov
just a few weeks ago and honestly I
haven't stopped thinking about it since
it's a huge game and facing the mean
streets woods and factories of tarkov is
an undertaking that's daunting in its
scope now I'm not as seasoned escape
from tarkov player by any stretch of the
imagination I realize that I still have
so much to learn but in a few weeks that
I've been playing it I've realized that
it is a game that punishes you for your
mistakes and I like so many other
players are there I'm guilty of one of
the seven deadly sins of escape from
tarkov
every player once looped that's just a
simple fact of life when it comes to the
world of a hardcore looter shooter now
many tarkov escapee are driven by that
lust for a virtual firearms suit of body
armor or brand-new backpack to some the
sound of a sniper rifle or automatic
weapon is more of a dinner bell than a
warning sign the echo of a shot becoming
a beacon as they turn their character
towards it and hammer the spring key
towards the action the craving for
virtual gains and stacks of readers can
affect the mentality of a scav or PMC
who suddenly become prepared to roll the
dice for a shot of big gains what may on
paper seem to be an insurmountable
assault against a trio of geared players
or the map's Gavroche becomes oh so much
more alluring when there's the chance of
scoring valuable equipment the potential
for loss is easily eclipsed by the
potential for gain for even the most
level-headed of players sure it may pay
off here are their but the tunnel vision
that the lust for loop rings has been
the death of many a bear and you set as
they relentlessly chase that high into
the trees losing all sense of patience
until you're reminded of the fragility
of your existence with a Mosin round
through the temple that thought will
follow you through the respawns and into
the market of tarkov choosing the
min/max approach of stripping your
weapons to get the best deals on the
in-game merchants and throwing yourself
into the in-game flea market trying to
milk every ruble dollar and euro offer a
twisted dopamine rush as you continue to
succumb to the lust for more ill-gotten
gains
I myself am a lute pig and I'm sure you
either are one yourself or no one in
your squad these are the players that
will dive headfirst directly into the
corpses of freshly downed enemies and
feverishly start dragging and dropping
every morsel of loot into their
inventory now I tried to play it in a
way that if I'm with a squad and I get
the kill then I get first dibs of the
loot they can have what either I don't
want or I simply can't carry but their
gluttonous loot devour is among us see a
fresh corpse and all following of simple
looting etiquette goes out the window
they just see the gear I want to feast
they run through tarkov as if it's a
war-torn all-you-can-eat buffet with the
attitude of oh just a little more one
more bite just another taste of loot now
escaping with a backpack that is fit to
burst is undoubtedly a great feeling but
the loop gluttons often go for the goods
and the expense of safety and sanity
their deaths come while they're neck
deep in the gear set of a recent kill
waiting for a weapon box or safe to give
up their goods or struggling with the
tetris-like
inventory management so they can squeeze
that last carton of milk into their scab
bag one of the things I learned early on
in tarkov is that the loop really isn't
yours until you escape with it and that
sometimes it's best to leave a corpse or
weapon box unlooted
if it means you can get out with your
bounty bear a mind a little profit is
still profit so don't be a pig now
[Music]
now this is a sin I am definitely guilty
of in escape from tarkov and I'm not
ashamed to admit it although it does
cause me some issues sometimes I try to
look at my relationship with my
inventory like a dragon guarding its
mountain of gold but I realize I'm not
as majestic or as mythical so I'm
probably closer to a shut-in hoarder
than I am smile regardless if like me
your inventory is fit to burst then
chances are there is probably a lot that
could be sold or simply used are you
really going to get around to using
those 7 aks why are you holding on to
attachments for pistols and rifles you
don't even have and what's the point in
having a box full of Makarov but no ammo
or mags for them but I want you to know
I get it I really really do there's
something oddly satisfying about seeing
your stash so full of potential toys to
play with the trouble is though for me
at least they're going unused I'm
talking about gear fear maybe you got
something incredible from a weapon case
or took down another player and found a
wildly kitted out rifle so you take it
back to your hideout took it away safely
no stash excitedly don't you find and
then never take it out again we've all
done it but while your gear is gathering
dust its potential is going to waste it
is sell it on a flea market to buy some
kit you're actually comfortable with
losing or commit and use that fancy new
weapon you are so excited to loop
because when it comes to your loadout
escape from tarkov is about investing in
your success and honestly you'll get
what you pay for
take em over example say you're heading
into a raid with your nice a k105 that
you've pimped out with your favorite
scopes and attachments but your cheats
out and bought the crappy ammo that's
going to get you killed as soon as you
meet any armored player or scavenger and
while it may cost tens of thousands of
rubles to fill your m4 with high damage
and armor penetrating ammunition it
costs four hundred thousand dollars to
fire this weapon for twelve seconds
there are two things to bear in mind the
best defense is often a good offense and
sometimes you got to spend money to make
money
escape from tarkov is not a game that
will let you get away with being lazy
and rather broad terms it's an
experience that requires preparation and
information to its very core
if you're too lazy to tidy up their
inventory and get some things organized
then chances are you're going to forget
a key item in a raid grabbing a splint
will slip your mind or forgetting a
bandage will leave you bleeding out
after a scarf Clips your leg God knows
it's happened to me and neglecting
quests and failing to build at your
hideout is gonna leave you short on
options after a long session or so
you'll make crap or sad you don't add
you map knowledge is also key so take
your time with scarrans or offline mode
to familiarize yourself with your
surroundings the tarkov wiki is also a
great resource when it comes to learning
the specifics around weapons armor and
ballistics you need to take the time to
get to know your kit if you want to go
into a raid feeling like a walking tank
there are some players that aren't
really in it for the loot these wrathful
players want the fight more than they
care about their finances this is the
squad mate that's rushing through
brambles causing a racket
clanking across metal walkways chasing a
kill or whoring you along onto the next
fight when you're organizing your
inventory or reloading your magazines
those that thirst for death or glory and
charge into battle ill-prepared and with
little thought beyond the kill and are
usually met with the respawn screen more
often than they are fat loot there also
exists some sort of unwritten code of
honor between scabs that the objective
is to work together against the fully
geared PMC's you can all get out with a
little somethin'-somethin which is
exactly why the AI scabs don't attack
each other but the wrathful players
don't see an ally in the disheveled form
of a scavenger they're the ones that
find a part to resist clicking on the
unarmored head of a mumbling Russian
scrounger which again is often a root of
mais as the other nearby Kalashnikov
carrying collectors swarm in your
position and while many enjoy the
pursuit of combat be careful that your
fury does not go unchecked for down that
path leads those to become the worst of
scum and villainy the dreaded exit
campus
there are many elements of tarkov that
can leave its players with a green hue
of envy
whether that's towards another player's
items bank balance or at times even
their skill level you may have even felt
a pang of guilt when teaming up with a
friend admiring their weapons and
equipment while a small but rather loud
part of your psyche hopes that they
don't survive this raid so you can take
all their stuff for yourself as the
tarkoff tenants say thou shalt not covet
thy squad mates rifle it's easy to get
lost in your wishes while playing tarkov
wishing for certain items a larger bank
balance wishing you had this skill of
shroud the knowledge of pestle or the
composure of Feherty X and while they
are all obviously great girls to have in
your survival career a raid spent
wishing there's a raid wasted but as
envious as you allow yourself to be or
as powerful as you become remember in
tarkov it's not just the bigger fish you
need to be wary of it's also the little
one looking at you through a scope from
a bush it is often said that pride comes
before a fall and a no game is that more
true than this one once you're decked
out in some of the finest clobber the
Russian black market can offer a weapon
that costs more than my university debts
and a backpack larger than a London flat
it's easy to start feeling a little
invincible that you're the baddest thing
to grace the rafters of this fine
factory but tarkov has a grounding
quality to it they will often hand out
portions of humble pie like a grandma
with a baking addiction and don't be too
proud to seek out help either many of my
raids have only found success because
I've used a map on the wiki to figure
out where the hell I can escape to as
well as reaching out to friends and
squad mates to watch my back or help me
on a quest it's perfectly fine to feel
proud with a raid gone well or a weapon
that you've spent 30 minutes tinkering
with and perfecting but keep in the back
of your mind that it could all be
snatched away with the pull of a trigger
after all the higher on your loot
covered pedestal you climb the heart of
that fall will feel
[Music]
now you may ask what makes me so acutely
aware of all these sinful wrongdoings
well that's because in the month ish
that I've been playing this game I have
done them all I'm a huge sinner I'm as
sinful as they come I've got my
teammates killed by getting bloodthirsty
I've scrounged away roubles and rifle
rounds and I have indeed felt that very
bitter pang of envy when I see what my
squad mates discover in weapon crates
and for that I will no doubt be sent to
the very deepest depths of tarkov hell
destined to only ever loot tosses and
PRS rounds for my plethora of sins
[Music]